why are we waiting another week before
we are asking the general public to put
a mask on when they go into a shop well
we we it is of course safe in shops and
we're we've currently got the guidance
that people should wear a mask in shops
and we're making that mandatory I think
it's a good step forward it's all part
of our strategy of trying to make the
transmission of coronavirus as low as
possible while also allowing people to
get back to the the sorts of things that
they love to do and and restoring the
good things in life that we had to
unfortunately clamp down on during the
peak so it's all part of the overall
program the overall strategy to keep the
transmission of the virus down while
it's allowing other you know other parts
of life like going shopping to get going
again yeah except the scientists that we
did a montage I don't know if you saw
yesterday on Sky News including Jonathan
Bantam it's saying there was no evidence
at all that masks made a difference did
they get it wrong no the scientists have
been brilliant throughout this crisis
but part of science is that you
constantly learn and one of the things
we've learnt about this virus is that
there's more asymptomatic transmission
than than anybody thought of and there's
also been developments in in
understanding of the spread now on masks
it's a it's always it's a balanced
decision but there is there's benefit of
having a mask especially a benefit to
other people if you have if you are an
asymptomatic carrier of the corona virus
I feel fine you don't have any symptoms
but you do have the disease maybe it's
before those symptoms have come through
the it's now clear that you can transmit
the disease this is novel for a corona
virus and and the scientists didn't know
this at the start that's no criticism of
their scientists at all I mean we always
knew it was airborne didn't we so it
would make sense to wear a face covering
we saw many other countries putting face
coverings on including Scott
and and yet we still didn't because the
scientists were telling us not to well
the in Scotland they're taking broadly
the same decision that broadly at the
same time that's what's happened across
the UK throughout this is the whole of
the UK has essentially taken the same
decisions with some small distinctions
it's mostly about timing
so confusion then because I mean I was
looking I was chatting to your colleague
George Eustace yesterday he didn't know
that it wasn't compulsory for a client
to wear a face mask in a hairdressers he
didn't know that he was arguing that
that it was it isn't according to the
rules so far may change but up to date
up to today it isn't
and your cabinet colleagues yesterday
also seemed remarkably confused I'm sure
you seen the front page of The Telegraph
today where they're both going in coming
out the same shop one of them's got a
face mask on the other one hasn't we
spoke to the manager of that prat store
and he says he's confused
the message is confused isn't it okay
that was this picture was before we'd
announced the change in the policy I I
announced that changing the policy in
the House of Commons yesterday explained
to me then should who was right who
would be right today coming out of that
store well the advice until the 24th of
July giving businesses time to make sure
they can get their processes in place
and make sure that we can that we can
implement this smoothly the advice and
now is that face coverings are
recommended in shops but not mandatory
that's been the position for some time
and we're tightening that up to say that
they are mandatory from the 24th of July
so that's just let's use presses an
example because that's your picture that
we're looking at from the 24th of July
do you need to wear a face mask coming
out of pret you do need to wear a face
mask in prep because prep is a shop and
this is a restaurant in the restaurant
you Thank You Kay I was just going to
come onto to describe that so a hospital
in hospitality
so in a restaurant there needs to be
table service if there's table service
then it is not necessary to have a mask
but in any shop you do need the mask so
if you're going up to the counter in
Pratt to buy takeaway that is a shot
that is Pratt operating as a shop but if
you go to your local pub you can't go to
the bar in fact they've been stories of
people putting you know but stopping
people from go to the going to the bar
you can't go to the bar and the reason
there is because of the risk of
transmission over the bar and therefore
it's table service and a mask is not
needed ever a but when you go into a
shop a mask is okay the law from the
24th of July okay I think that's clear
Blackburn aren't saying that people
should wear masks in the office is that
a good idea so we will not be
recommending masks in the office but I
respect what Blackburn have done in fact
you know Blackburn has taken action
locally because their rates of of
positive cases are higher than many
other places around the country and
they're not as high as Leicester but
they are higher than the national
average and though council and Blackburn
are doing a fantastic job at taking
local action themselves to try to tackle
the problems in Blackburn er okay let's
whisk through another couple before I
have to let you go sorry about the
confusion about where you should have
been this morning Lester when are you
lifting the lockdown in Leicester well
we're taking the decision later this
week so by by the end of the week we
will announce the next steps on
Leicester whether to make any changes
and if so what changes to make that'll
all be driven by the data and our
assessment of of how well they the team
are doing locally capital gains tax
apparently your colleague the Chancellor
reportedly looking to raise capital
gains tax to call back some of the money
that it cost us for the to fund the Cova
crisis any truth in that
as far as I understand there is no
proposal and there is a the the the
Chancellor is not looking at tax changes
now we've just had the summer economic
statement and apparently reviews like
this are normal all of the time and not
connected to any decision one way or the
other okay
particularly bugbear of mine I've don't
often get a straight answer to this but
the health secretary will know the
answer
clapping for carers and Thank You NHS
doesn't extend to paying for their
parking it did during the height of
covert it's not going to now is that
right or not that's not right now the
the free parking is extended and and you
know that's a that's an important thing
that we've done during the crisis and
we're in fact also putting money into
building more car parks next to
hospitals because it's not just the
staff who want to park it's their
patients who need to be able to park as
well at the moment there's very few
visitors to hospitals because of the
infection control procedures and so that
is so we've been able to to to do this
for staff okay and final thought we're
hearing more and more about long-term
Effects of covert and multi organ damage
extreme fatigue etc etc given that you
suffered from it I I am concerned
thankfully not for me I'm fine but I am
concerned there's increasing evidence
that as minority of people but a
significant minority have long term
impacts and it could be quite
debilitating and so with we've set up an
NHS service to support the those with
long term impacts of kovat and also
we've put almost ten million pounds into
research into these long-term effects so
it is I'm it is something that I'm I'm
worried about we've taken action on both
through the NHS and through the the
research
activities you know it's one of the
consequences of this being a novel virus
just like we were talking about at the
start we're constantly learning about
the impact of it and it does appear that
for some people there's a there's a
there's a pretty debilitating long-term
impact quite similar to a post-viral
fatigue syndrome that you do get with
many viruses and it's really important
that we support people who are in that
situation and also that we do the
research to find out what we can do
about it so many people often want to
give politicians are kicking butt you
know you guys are doing and girls are
doing what you can
during this epidemic that we didn't know
anything who could have possibly have
known what covert 19 was going to do to
our country and indeed to the world
what's been the most challenging part
for you up till now have you been able
to sleep at night I have actually
because my attitude is you do everything
you possibly can during the day and then
you go to bed and you get up and do you
do the same again and it you know the
decisions have been extraordinary and
very large you know the ballot the the
issues that you balance are very very
significant on both sides you know the
hardest part has been without doubt the
fact that as we've learnt more so we've
had to change policy and then you have
to come on the and explain why your
policy is different today to yesterday
and and the the truth is is because
we're constantly learning you know we
didn't know what the secretary no no
that's not the house but that's a
pleasure and always it always a joy the
point is that you constantly having to
review decisions that you've made
according to what we've learnt about the
virus and this point about asymptomatic
transmission is a case in point
you know the before this corona virus
there were six previous corona viruses
and none of them had a symptomatic
transmission so understandably the
advice at the start was is this one
won't either but it does and it's one of
the hardest things to deal with because
you know it's hard enough stopping a
virus when it and when people with
symptoms have got it but when people
without symptoms are passing it on it
makes it just so much harder and you
know the whole world is struggling with
this